den Laden hinter mir dürftet ihr
vielleicht kennen ich werde hier heute
einen Tag lang Pizza backen ich habe mir
schon viele viele Gedanken zu Pizza
gemacht selbst geübt aber heute lerne
ich von einem echten Profi ich bin sehr
gespannt was dieser Tag heute bringt ich
will alles lernen so viel sage ich euch
ich habe große Erwartungen deshalb gehen
wir direkt rein lernen nun zur kennen
den Pizzabäcker und haben einen guten
Tag los geht's und hier sind wir jetzt
bei der Italiener neben mir ist ein
Italiener und zwar wirklich absolute
Legende der hat die letzte Pizza
gebacken die auch im Video gesehen habt
hier ist die Leute das wollte ich euch
zeigen ich war nämlich um ehrlich zu
sein schon mal hier essen bei dem Laden
und guckt euch bitte diese Pizza an
glaube von ihm kann ich viel viel lernen
ihr wisst ich bin Pizza begeistert wer
ist es nicht und du wirst mir heute
erstmal zeigen wie man eigentlich eine
Pizza machen ganz genau so was sind die
Steps als erstes machst du natürlich
eigentlich erst mal Teig das lassen wir
heute mal ein bisschen aus sofort ein
Wagen das ist nichts austeilt
wahrscheinlich genau
42 Stunden sind wir jetzt schon drin
genau dann müsste jetzt also Temperatur
ist eigentlich bei 24 Grad verarbeiten
hier den den jetzt zwei drei Grad aber
das macht
diese Temperatur ist sehr wichtig
Temperatur vom Ofen und die
Teigtemperatur die spielt eine richtige
Rolle ich freue mich wirklich dass du
mir das heute ein bisschen erklärst weil
ich habe ja auch so mein mein Heimat
Pizzaofen so einen kleinen Gasofen aber
das hier können wir auch mal drauf
eingehen ist natürlich ein bisschen Baby
ne das ist ein wunderschöner Ofen immer
ähm
kann direkt aus
funktioniert mit Gas nicht mit Holzkohle
wahrscheinlich auch in diesen Tagen
nicht das nicht das günstigste aber
freue mich auf die Pizzen die wieder
rausziehen können und natürlich ist der
Teig vielleicht das Herzstück der Pizza
aber es gibt noch viele kleine
Handgriffe und vor allem den Pizzaiolo
der die Pizza wirklich zu einer guten
Pizza macht und du zeigst mir jetzt wie
du das machst ich gucke mir das ganz
genau an also wir gehen jetzt ganz
vorsichtig den Teig nehmen versuchen die
Kugel so rum wie möglich damit wir eine
Runde Pizza kriegen dann gehen wir vom
Norden nach Süden versuchen Sauerstoff
in den Rändern rein also Luft
reinzupressen von Norden nach Süden und
wir halten uns an einer Technik die uns
hier zumindest zwei drei Zentimeter Rand
gibt okay ja wenn das gemacht gemacht
ist kann man es ein bisschen umdrehen
noch mal ein bisschen montieren so dann
gibt es halt zwei Techniken ich benutze
die Technik zum Drehen eine ist zum
Halten und eine zum Ziehen so und wir
versuchen nicht den Rand kaputt zu
machen aber du machst gerade schon
Hälfte Geschwindigkeit eigentlich ne
normalerweise steht der hier und sowieso
Technik genau
macht natürlich kann man die auch drehen
schlagen oder werfen okay kein Problem
wir sind natürlich im Normalbetrieb wir
machen jetzt nicht den Laden hier kommen
und ich ein bisschen was lernen möchte
deshalb macht dein Ding so sieht das
dann in Echtzeit ausgehen das ist krass
da werde ich heute nicht hinkommen aber
ich werde auf jeden Fall einiges lernen
das merke ich jetzt schon keine Ahnung
wie ist das geil so gerade so bei diesen
großen Gerichten und Profi zu gucken
Olivenöl
Basilikum einen Löffel Pesto rein genau
das gleiche
[Musik]
von jeder Sekunde in diesem Bereich in
diesem lesen ich kann sein dass ich 10
Sekunden zu spät kurz mal reingucken
hebe und Roller ist verbrannt dafür bin
ich heute da ja ich habe auch alles ein
Auge versucht die Luft in den Seiten
rein zu treffen diesen Handgriff kenne
ich halt noch gar nicht ne so die so
gleichmäßig Aussehen
anhalten und dann andere muss und dann
so mit dem Rand sieht man quasi den du
musst aber versuch nicht zu berühren
okay
so richtig ins kalte Wasser geworfen ne
so diese neue Technik Hochbetrieb hier
gefühlt das Ding ist die wird nicht
größer ich glaube ich arbeite nicht mit
einem Druck also die linke Hand weiß
genau hier ist das voll intuitiv so du
formst du den Rand ja da werden wir
schon z.B das Problem haben dass dieser
Bereich dann nicht so hoch kommt aber
das ist kein Problem versuche es weiter
ich kann es dir besser käme hier
versuche ich nur festhalten und den mit
denen hier drin und ziehen du ziehst
länglich aber du drehst oder dadurch
wird es aber hier führe ich mir ja noch
daran ja okay
jetzt belegen wir unsere schöne
pizzabrontaise mit 100% Pistazien aus
Bronze
ja aus meinem Dorf du bist bei den du ja
dran das ist ja deine Lieblingspizza bis
jetzt weil ich habe für später auch noch
was mitgebracht ja du kriegst eine Kelle
Tomatensoße drauf ein Löffel reicht
tatsächlich und am besten ist wenn du
mit dem Herz anfängst leicht drückst du
dir das alles in die Seite und die
Spitze ist dann nur zum Korrigieren und
diese Rillen die entstehen
einfach nehmen in dem Punkt
rein guck mal rein da sieht man schon so
wo die anderen Pistolen weil das ist
sehr perfekt genau und da haben wir
schon drauf gebacken das heißt der Stein
ist nicht so heiß dann verbrennen
deshalb sollte man die Pizza
auf dem gleichen Platz zu tun
[Musik]
genau gut jetzt kommt die zweite
s warten wir kurz das hier ein bisschen
an der Seite Farbe kommt und schon ein
bisschen äh hoch so dass der Teig von
unten wirklich ein bisschen fest ist
aber ich kann sein dass wenn wir zu
schnell reingehen dann Loch reinmachen
durch die westlichkeit der Soße des Käse
und alles ist ja auch dünne deshalb muss
er schon ein bisschen stabil sein
in dem Fall jetzt zum Beispiel könnten
wir schon mal leicht ansetzen drehen
aber wieder auf den gleichen Platz
sobald ein zehn Meter vorbei ist und der
geht auf einen anderen Platz ist hier
unten rechts schwarz ich verstehe okay
so wir nehmen es an der Seite und drehen
die so zack genau und versuchen dann
gleich einen Platz genau
wirklich alleine hier bei Mama 300
Pizzen kann es passieren dass der ein
oder andere durch die hohe
Geschwindigkeit die man einsetzt dass
das auch nicht alles zu 100 % ist
natürlich da ein perfekte Pizzeria aber
natürlich Hochbetrieb ist richtig hoch
bitte ist die eine nicht perfekt rund
oder nicht aber genau das macht auch die
traditionelle Pizza aus keine perfektes
das ist ja alles handgemacht eine
maschinelle Sachen
genau wir sehen jetzt die Seite ist
fertig die ist auch schon durch damit
die nicht Wasser entzieht halten wir die
ein bisschen hier damit die schneller
neben der Flamme gemacht wird und
nochmal so schön Farbe bekommen
ist fast ohne Höhenunterschiede wir
hätten ein bisschen lange reden und dann
Tieren sagten die auch manchmal ein
bisschen ab und das ist deine du hast
hier eine Schwachstelle
drauf macht und dann schneidet ja ja
immer danach frisch drauf gemacht ja
genau
auch mit Pistazien verfeinert natürlich
dann zupfen wir ein bisschen frische
Büffelmozzarella Parmesan und dann kommt
natürlich gehackte Pistazien aus
Blomberg dann darf das auch raus weil
ich 18 meine erste Pizza hat sich gerade
auf dem Weg gemacht ich bin schon ein
bisschen stolz ich meine ich habe noch
nicht alles daran selbst gemacht aber
daran arbeiten wir jetzt richtig unter
Strom so aufgeregt Feier das Alter
immer genau die ist noch perfekt du
kannst ihn schon rein tun
aber das möchte ich bitte dass man das
gehört haben
das war kein schönes Geräusch aber die
Pizza
ich habe eine Frage an dich wie lange
darf man für eine Pizza brauchen
was mir bitte eine Pizza stoppen
kein Problem
rund Norden nach Süden Nordens nach
Süden nach Süden nun zur Technik lang
ziehen langziehen ohne den Rand
anzurühren und jetzt kommt die
max-technik nämlich noch mit dazu ab
jetzt ziehe ich ein bisschen lang mit
meinem Knöcheln sich schon aber die hat
echt richtig viel Gluten das merkt man
auf jeden Fall so was sagt die Zeit Erik
20 eine Minute 20 kein Problem vor dem
Ofen kommt auf jeden Fall Mozzarella
drauf
gekocht Zwiebel kommt danach drauf ab in
den Ofen drauf zack ablegen hinten nach
vorne die Größe ist noch nicht gut was
sagt die Zeit
Halbzeit die backt ja auch fast 3
Minuten deshalb
habe
ich schon seine Vorarbeiten und
machen die aber schon belegt wie hätte
ich dir noch größer bekommen sollen
weißt du also man muss die ziehen aber
ich habe die falsch gezogen wenn du
immer so ziehst geht die natürlich
wieder zurück es gibt auch eine Technik
am ziehen ganz normal aber das sieht
nicht verkehrt aus seinem Hofmeister ich
glaube die Größe wird nicht perfekt sein
okay aber du sagst mir 2 cm aber das
liegt nicht am Geschmack würde ich sagen
waren es noch mal so 20 30 Sekunden die
wir brauchen der anzieht sich verkehrt
aus Leute also ich hoffe Eric wird
vielleicht nicht allzu viel mehr kann
können wir jetzt gerade Konkurrenz
gemacht
jetzt halte ich noch einmal hoch eins
zwei zwei
andere Seite
1 2 3 raus mit dem Gutscheincode
15:45 Uhr alter Schwede ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass es so knapp ist aber ja
jetzt musst du Eric würde ich sagen
einen Geschmackstest machen sie sieht
sehr sehr gut aus bisschen klein ja das
würde ich auch sagen wenn ich sie am
Tisch bin gekommen würde aber die fühlt
sich unglaublich gut an ja wie sieht sie
denn von unten aus ne das ist ja auch
immer Punkt
so haben wir es gerne so muss das sein
guten Appetit
hallo die Pizza ist sehr gut gebacken
aber der Teig ist eine 11 von 10 der
Teig ist unnormal danke
ich glaube die Basics habe ich jetzt
verstanden ich weiß wie man eine Pizza
ausformt und du hast gesagt es ist ganz
okay das ist alles was ich heute eher
träumen konnte und deshalb bin ich schon
mal ein bisschen zufrieden ich habe aber
noch eine kleine Besonderheit
mitgebracht ich habe mir zwei Pizzen
überlegt ich möchte dir gerne mal zeigen
oh ich habe hier alles alles was ich
brauche werde ich mache eine Pizza kennt
ihr vielleicht Thunfisch Zitrone
Basilikum Pesto eine weitere Pizza hier
drin ist San Daniele Schinken also ein
super guter italienischer Schinken dazu
und vierte Tomaten ich backe jetzt mal
die beiden Pizzen zeig sie dir und wer
weiß vielleicht ist ja so gut dass sie
auf die Karte kommt wenn Sie nun zu
gefällt die oberste Instanz fangen wir
an mit der Zitronen Pesto Pizza
[Musik]
ein bisschen aufwärmt hier ich bin sehr
gespannt was du zu der Kreation sagen
wirst jetzt gehen wir ran Pesto aus
meiner Küche wir waren einkaufen und
haben leckeres Pesto selbst gemacht
schaut euch das an Pinienkerne Basilikum
Olivenöl Parmesan alles was das Herz
begehrt bisschen Zitrone noch mit rein
und das ist ein Bestandteil von meiner
Pizza Pinienkerne und jetzt schöne
italienische aus Süditalien Zitronen
Pizza Nummer eins ist fertig Pinienkerne
Pesto zitronenpesto Thunfisch wirklich
ich habe sie ja schon mal gegessen aber
noch nie mit so einem guten Teig das
wird krass
[Musik]
bist du so gut probiert einfach mal ein
Stückchen
mir schmeckt die sehr gut dieses
Basilikum im Mund explodiert nach der
frische die Pinienkerne das wäre sogar
vielleicht eine Variante hier auf der
Karte aber wir müssen ja noch die andere
probieren ohne dass die andere fertig
ist okay es geht in eine gute Richtung
Leute ich mache jetzt noch die zweite
Variante und ich bin schon halt bei
dieser so lecker wirklich die nehmen wir
jetzt ein paar von unseren vierten
Tomaten ja noch in so einem Tomatenöl
drin sind
San Daniele Schinken extra bei unserem
Lieblingsladen geholt wie bei jedem
Gericht sind natürlich auch bei Pizza
die Zutaten entscheiden deshalb
Feinkostladen nur die besten Zutaten für
die hoffentlich beste Pizza
[Musik]
dann lege ich hier so ein bisschen zu
den einzelnen Stücken und jetzt für die
Farbe Rucola ein wenig frittierter
Rucola in die Mitte braun da wow optisch
schon mal einsa Produktauswahl auch
einsam
probieren wir auch so ein schönes Stück
von unten verkehrt aus
wir schenken ist total mein Ding Tomaten
sind auch gut eingelegt
weil schaut ihr besser geschmeckt es ist
schwer für mich zu sagen der Schinken
bringt mir sehr leckeren kernigen
eingeschlafen das Ding ist die andere
Pizza diese besonders die kriegt man das
ist halt um was Feines gute Idee aber
die kriegt man fast in jeder Pizzeria in
der paar marocola und Parmaschinken
vorne und Parmesan ist eine wirklich
eine geschmacklich Explosion durch den
frischen Basilikum pinkeln und diese
geriebene Zitrone komplett andere Welt
[Musik]
nun so Dankeschön an alle erster Stelle
dass du mir so viel beigebracht hast
dass ich so viel lernen durfte mein Tag
beim Italiener geht vorbei wir haben
hier vor mir die Pizza die tatsächlich
auf die Karte kommen wird und du darfst
es sagen es ist die max Pizza 1 auf der
Karte werdet ihr sie als Max Pizza
einfach bestellen können für unbestimmte
Zeit sagt euch eins ich selbst liebe
diese Pizza gefallen sag dir nun zu
liebe Grüße und probiert die Pizza aus
danke schön noch mal Danke auch an den
Laden das hier drehen durfte ich glaube
ihr hattet hoffentlich genauso viel Spaß
wie ich wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal
wieder hier oben gibt's für euch
vorgeschlagenes Video da drunter könnt
ihr den Kanal abonnieren wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Mal die nehme ich mit nach
Hause